[Music]
janice is with us in oklahoma city to
start this hour off
hi janice how are you hi dave
uh i'm doing okay i'm really pretty um
very concerned about my finances
i'm 70 years old
i have no retirement my husband and i
neither one have a retirement
we are not in agreement about what we
should do with the cash that we do
have we have 25 000
cash no cds nothing that's it
the question is we owe 27
000 on our home and the value of the
home is about 250
000. we have
thousand dollar debt on a car
uh my husband wants to take the money
that we have
and pay off the car and then he says
apply the three hundred fifty dollar
mass car
payment towards paying off the house
my problem is i'm so stressed i at least
want to have a house to live in
and the way i see things i don't think i
can live anywhere cheaper than where i
live right now
i don't think i could even live in an
apartment for what we
would be paying a month on our home
so i need some help here
what are you living on what's your
income
we have two thousand dollars a month
social security
combined i have some income
that i get above that with a
job that i have but it's pretty
physically challenging
um i'm able to do it now but
you know i don't know how long i'll be
able to do that
what do you make uh i probably another
two thousand a month on that
okay is your husband able to work
he has a part-time job uh
it's kind of whenever the the
store owner needs him and
so he has occasional income but nothing
that we count on
is he able to work
um a little
so he's got physical limitations yes he
does
okay he's got health problems yeah
okay and that's part of you know our
situation
we've had large medical bills and we've
also made some real bad
cash investments
what do you do that makes you two
thousand dollars
uh i clean homes and it's physically
demanding
okay it's good money but it's physically
demanding
um
hmm
hey how many cars do you have
we have a paid off
old very dependable pickup
and then we have the one card that we
have the outstanding dead on
we also have an old roadster
that's probably i would say about a ten
thousand dollar
value on it
i'm sorry but the roadster is gone
okay um you have not
i'm sure that's gonna break his heart
but i'm sorry
um it's gone and then that gives us ten
thousand dollars to put towards the
house
um because the roadster will sell for
enough to pay off your car
we can leave 15 000 in your emergency
fund put 10 000 towards the house and
then that leaves you 17 to go
and you guys get in the business of the
next 17 months or so getting that house
paid off
okay because with no debt at all you can
make it
it's not going to be pretty but you can
make it
right right um you know i
we don't spend money i mean everybody
spends money it
costs money to do anything but the main
thing we do is we eat out
and that's not yep a lot we don't go
here's the thing here's the thing if you
want to keep this house you're going to
start living like you're completely
bankrupt
because you got to clean this mess up
you do not have wiggle room here
that's where all this stress is coming
from in your stomach and why you called
me
yes so you can't eat out
you're broke eating out is causing you
to clean toilets
okay yep i agree yeah and so
you know i'm sorry about in the future
you may
may be able to but right now you've got
to get a roadster sold you got to get
your car paid off and you got to get
your house paid off
and you've got 25 000 in a roadster to
pull all this off
and a 2 000 income that's questionable
because we don't know how much longer
you can do this at 70 years old
right so we have got to get you clear of
this debt
before you're before you start losing
the ability to work like he has
otherwise you're going to end up selling
this house and buying a condo for a
hundred thousand and have a hundred
thousand dollar slush fund to live on
and have a life now you can go and do
that now if you want
okay i'm listening to you well you got a
250 000 house right
yes so if you sell it today you're
debt-free take a hundred thousand by a
hundred thousand dollar condo
two-bedroom
move yourself into it and that's your
retirement home
and that's how you're going to retire
and that that enables you to
not be stressed and not be worried and
you've got a hundred thousand dollars
to invest over there it'll make you a
little bit of money and
you know that's a much better
mathematical equation but i'm guessing
that that's going to cause an awful lot
of emotional pain
well and also you know the hoa thieves
would be
no problem no no no
you you can live in a 100 000 condo in
oklahoma city
it's just going to come down to making
the choice janice like you're going to
have to make a choice you're either
going to
get out of this debt or you're going to
have to leave that like
something has to give this is not
working right now which is why you feel
that tightness in your chest but you can
fix it you've got
several ways to fix it but you have to
make a choice and commit to doing that
you can't
he's going to have to work all his
health will allow him you're going to
work all your health will allow you
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
you're going to sell the roadster
and you guys are going to get serious
about paying this thing off otherwise
you need to sell it
and move to a hundred thousand dollar
condo you'll be better off
or something like that